it's not fun talking about Apple I've
got one of these things I get it it's in
everyone's pocket it's probably spying
on me right now it could post what I'm
doing on the internet that would be
weird uh here's Apple CEO Tim Cook in
2017 praising China and talking about
how their leadership aligns with his
um China's done an unbelievable job of
lifting people out of poverty they've
done an incredible job I mean far beyond
what any country has done we were
talking about 19 mid 90s to today the
biggest change is the number of people
that have been pulled out of poverty by
far and we should all applaud that
and then we should all feel good about
it and so there are in in the
environmental leadership
today
is very clear and it aligns completely
with Apple's values the Chinese uh
environmental governments I mean they're
they're very fixated on on uh doing the
right things to avert climate change and
this is something that means a lot to us
as well and so what what we always try
to do is find the areas where you can
work together find the areas of
commonality and then the things that you
disagree with take time to understand
how somebody sees it and if I'm going to
get criticized for that then so be it so
it's really interesting here first off
uh China right now is opening more coal
plants than any other country on Earth
but he likes again this is back in 2017.
he likes China because of what they're
doing with green energy but what he
really likes is the same thing that the
NBA likes he's a businessman and I don't
besmerge him as a businessman a
businessman is in the business of
business apple is a company wants to
make money and what do companies do once
you've exhausted the amount of people
that you can make money from in the
United States right they've kind of Hit
the limit most of us have iPhones most
of us have their products you might pay
for iMusic or iTunes or whatever it is
or you're downloading movies then they
have to find new markets to go to so
China is a massive Market in that
they've got billions of people over
there uh here's some info from Bloomberg
on on the coal plant situation because
again he's praising them for going green
this is from September of 22. uh China
put more new coal plants into operation
last year than the rest of the world
combined and it's proposed coal mines
account for almost a third of the global
total Bazaar that I don't see Tim Cook
talking [ __ ] about them today very very
weird